l'industrie dont les émissions ne sont
toujours pas réglementés d'ici 2020 la
moitié de l'augmentation des gaz à effet
de serre aux pays proviendra de
l'extraction pétrolière en alberta et ce
sont les canadiens qui en paie le prix
thomas mulcair accuse une fois de plus
les conservateurs de ne rien faire dans
la lutte contre le changement climatique
lui qui veut attirer l'attention sur son
programme environnemental promet
d'assumer un leadership dans ce domaine
mais avec un nouveau gouvernement
néo-démocrate en alberta thomas mulcair
at il vraiment une alliée henry john
hatley
la plateforme du npd albertain reste
plutôt vague sur la question des gaz à
effet de serre on donne les grandes
lignes mais pas nécessairement beaucoup
de détails le décret viendra par la
suite
arras est ce trailer a été d affaires 1
[ __ ] en alberta fait ce que la plupart des
partis politiques font en campagne loin
de vouloir tourner le dos à l'industrie
pétrolière russo nakhlé évite de se
prononcer sur un éventuel marché du
carbone dans sa province alors que le
npd fédéral lui promet un mécanisme est
pancanadien
l'alberta a déjà démontré qu'elle
voulait faire un pas dans cette
direction est sous la gouverne madame
note t on
on peut s'attendre à aller dans cette
direction de manière plus convaincante
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons de pouvoir nous asseoir le pouvoir
discuter de ces enjeux au niveau des
changements climatiques
mais rien de concret sur la table en
matière environnementale pour l'instant
le discours de ritchot nakhlé est
d'abord et avant tout économique et pour
steven guilbeault
il faudra faire preuve de patience
beaucoup d'espoir mais aussi une
certaine certaine dose de réalisme on
parle de l'alberta quand même dans une
province qui n'a pas toujours été le
meilleur élève concrétiser les
intentions verte reste un énorme défi
même après un bouleversement politique
et avec un parti qui se dit plus
sensible aux questions environnementales
que celui qui l'a précédé
ici marc godbout radio canada à ottawa